would you say
antifa or even yourself think that
violence is Justified to achieve these
goals
yes
almost all of the people protesting
against the Nazis and klansmen in
Charlottesville were peaceful but not
all of them
do you ever get tired of hiding your
identity what are your thoughts on
Peaceful protests what's the most
extreme thing you've done
I have been involved in anti-fascist
organizing and activism for 10 years now
I suppose I don't think that any person
can speak on behalf of a group so I'm
not speaking on behalf of like antifa as
such I'm speaking on behalf of sort of
myself as someone who is anti-fascist hi
I'm Emily hi Emily I'm Casper like the
Friendly Ghost like the Friendly Ghost I
love that this is my first time hearing
about antifa
um what is it antifa is shorthand for
anti-fascist and that sort of includes
the gamut of the bad isms you know so
anti-racism
anti-transphobia anti-islamophobia
anti-sexism but I think another core
tenant of it is probably also
anti-capitalism do you consider yourself
an organ organization
no antifa is not anything remotely close
to an organization it's sort of
decentralized and autonomous and what I
mean by that is like there's no Central
decision-making body in fact there is no
Center what do you define a fascist as
someone whose political beliefs and
values and the world they're trying to
create is one of hierarchy and
racialized domination nationalistic
domination and xenophobia and not
everybody from any specific group shares
exactly the same principles but
right now from my perspective antifa is
being portrayed as like government Enemy
Number One right like oh antifa is going
against America antifa is destroying the
American
philosophy I guess the way of life maybe
you feel like uh like this is like a
good thing like you guys want to be
known as like big top violent extreme
dogs I don't know yeah totally
um I think nowadays what it is has been
largely defined by the media you can't
see me but I'm wearing like full black
block I'm wearing all black I have a
black balaclava on and I think like that
is what antifa oftentimes means this
militant
black clad protester do you ever get
tired of hiding your identity it's kind
of fun actually putting on
a matching outfit with like dozens of
other people in a street protest
everyone just becomes a part of this
like moving organism where you can sort
of do anything and be anyone you want
and not face the consequences of those
actions right you know no face no case
is sort of the this term that gets
thrown around a lot so I guess that's
interesting because like
um with this belief do you think it
allows
allows people to be more violent without
consequences uh sure I mean it makes it
more possible to use violence to achieve
my means or something like that because
I know deep down in my heart and in my
soul
that it has to be done would you say uh
antifa or even yourself think that
violence is Justified to achieve these
goals
yes
violence has been a part of what it
means to be a human being the world that
we live in today with all the bombs and
all the guns and all the starving people
and the pollution these are all
different types of like violences or
something that are happening around the
world and I think our capacity for
violence is sort of like that which has
been taken from us and concentrated in
the hands of the police so you're
against the police like no police
fundamentally yes one of the most
memorable experiences of my life was
like watching the third precinct burn to
the ground in Minneapolis during the
George Floyd Uprising and that was the
first time in American history that
that's ever happened and within days
hundreds or thousands of police cars
across the country were like on fire you
don't think that kind of causes more
fear and irrationalization wouldn't that
be against what you are for which is
like a world where everyone can kind of
come together be you know peaceful
like I think the police sort of serve
three primary functions one is like to
uphold racialized white supremacy
protect the interests of the capitalist
ruling class and the third is to like
prevent social movements from being able
to change anything so then if like I'm
in my house someone breaks in and like
I'm in my closet or my bathroom like who
do I call hopefully not the cops because
they don't really seem to help with that
much I don't know I don't I don't have
an answer to that question I think
there's like a million different
solutions what do we do when harm
happens in our community what do we do
when people are committing wrongdoings
or whatever and I think the answer to
that is like a million different things
but definitely not the police
hey Claire hey dinghy are you enjoying
our ask me anything series I am and if
you are too like And subscribe for more
videos like this now let's get back into
the video have you ever broke anything
yes what uh
um
I'm trying to debate on whether or not I
should even talk about these sorts of
things what's the most extreme thing
you've done
um some of the most intense experiences
of my life were the resistance against
Milo yiannopoulos in Oakland who was a
right-wing grifter trying to give some
public talk that was shut down by
anti-fascists like you like tried to
stop him from talking or yeah something
something to that effect trying to
basically create such a scene that the
whole event has to be shut down
so I guess it's fair to say you don't
believe in free speech
uh well I don't think that everybody has
an equal
microphone per se the sort of abstract
notion of free speech
is less important to me than the content
of what's being shared and if what's
being shared is calls to to violence and
anti-Semitism and sexism and racism then
I don't give a about your
so-called Free Speech do you think it
would be okay to punch a Nazi hell yeah
uh yes absolutely we should not seed an
inch to those bastards and when they
have the goal to step out of their mom's
basement or whatever we do not give them
space in our communities to share their
disgusting and toxic and unforgivable
opinions
what are your thoughts on Peaceful
protests do you believe in it I think a
lot of the sort of like proper channels
of change working within the system
begging the people in power to make a
decision that doesn't you know
everybody over a lot of that stuff is
really degrading so we're begging them
to
to change the world when really we're
the ones us you the person watching this
YouTube video are the ones
who have the power to change the world
what's something you wish people knew
about you wow no one's ever asked me
that question before
you know I'm looking for love in the
world you know like in all sorts of
forms love is an answer like loving each
other loving ourselves loving the world
um and obviously it's not always like
the world's a sad Place sometimes I
didn't expect you to say you were
looking for love in the world for some
reason that made me emotional for a
second I guess I'm wondering like how do
you reconcile the two talking about love
a lot but then also being part of a
group that condones violence yeah
yeah that's a heavy question
um thanks you know the world is becoming
increasingly uninhabitable targeted
communities just continue to be targeted
racialized violence happening in the
world gendered violence and for me for
love to be able to truly proliferate in
this world so many of these systems need
to be torn down and so many new ones
need to pop up in their place and I
don't know what those new ones are I
don't have an answer for everything but
I know that the way that this world is
right now is just not conducive to love
how do you engage with individuals who
don't see eye to eye with antifa or have
a very violent reaction to the words
that is a very good question I think
it's one that people have been trying to
answer for a long time how do we
communicate across difference another
reason why I don't always think showing
up in full black block Garb is the most
strategic is because it makes people
assume a lot about you I put on this
mask like
less than one percent of the time or
something you know really so many of us
are doing so many different types of
community organizing work there's so
much more to like building an
anti-fascist world than just fighting
against fascists what is something that
you love about yourself
one thing I love about myself
is that I care
I care about things my heart gets warmed
when I see people in contact with their
capacity to be however they want to be
in the world to do whatever they want to
do in the world I'm trying to do that
too you know I'm trying to come into
contact with my source energy or
whatever to self-actualize and it's a
really hard it's a hard yeah I
appreciate your answers it seems like
you
really took some time to think about
some of those I may not agree with like
everything you stand for but I think I
agree like for the most part like just
being like a liberal person I think we
both can say that we want the world to
be like a better place I'm not a person
with like very strong political views my
beliefs are do whatever makes you happy
as long as it doesn't hurt other people
or yourself everybody can be happy
without harming others at the end of the
day yeah you're a decent human being
um and a cool guy well thanks Jasper the
Friendly Ghost uh right back at you
thank you